you're always giving a look like you
don't like do you wear sweats like ever
that's all i wear beyond sundays and
sometimes mondays
you kill it thank you i was like kind of
late today i was stuck in traffic for
three hours
so i didn't have my normal time and i
was like rushing on the stage but you
know i put it all together may not have
washed my hair but you can't smell it i
can't smell anything
it smells fantastic right yeah smell
anything it smells good though that's
where every day okay
is that what they're telling us what we
don't have to wash our hair every day
they are not telling us i think that
that is a thing you don't have to do it
every single day come on okay okay done
sold
you
okay watching the show and seeing how
emotional you get
as a mom especially like i'm not an ice
cream
she makes me wanna i don't even have
kids and you make me wanna cry um and
the performances were so beautiful so
like what was going on in your mind when
you were watching those performances
that made you feel so
i mean i guess i just understand
um
what it means to be a mom and to have
that love and like
just the
you know the sacrifice that moms do do
and a mother's job is never finished and
even seeing like jay's mom being a
single parent and like you know hunter
girl's mom working three jobs and stuff
like i can't even imagine
you know like it's look i've got all of
the privilege in the world and i've been
blessed be on measure as mom would say
and some days are still a challenge so i
can't even imagine when you're working
three jobs or you're a single parent and
it's just like you know that and to
raise them like they've turned out
all those kids like i just hope my
daughter
you know is as amazing and um
just as a good of a human as all those
people people i mean hunter girl is such
a wonderful human being and liam arlene
she's a wonderful human being i mean
just that i have observed from a
distance you know
so those let's just say that their
mama's raised them right
so that's why i'm emotional because i
feel it all i'm in the shoes i know yeah
yeah
how are you doing i know you fell a lot
in the mermaid outfit girl oh you was oh
oh lord
absolutely okay how are you feeling well
the next day so that night i flew
overnight to new york to go to the met
ball
and like had zero sleep
and then
i woke up and i was like i was actually
sore on my right
i thought i had a lot of padding in that
tail
but um you know
gotta do it for the tv
gotta do it for the likes
i did not plan for that to happen by the
way no
nah but it was great that it did
all i accept i accept everything yes
it's gonna be a really great meme if it
hasn't already been i don't know
i can't go on the internet it's dark
bear
[Laughter]
okay
i can't
i just post and ghost
i like that ooh energy that's a hashtag
post and ghost well thank you thank you
thank you
happy mother's day to you in the future
oh yes
you